joins us now from the european school of
management and technology thank you very
much for coming in we heard there from
an entrepreneur first of all that the
people who need these loans still can't
get them why then the interest rate cuts
well the ecb hopes that with the
interest rate cuts it's getting easier
again for banks to finance themselves
and thus to pass on lower interest rates
to their customers two problems though
arise the one is that many of these
customers still often have problems so
they are just not sound enough yet to
actually receive loans and the other one
is that the banks are not sound enough
so they even if they wanted to they
couldn't pass on these loans to their
customers is it more of a move to also
encourage investors because at the
moment the stock market has has jumped
up we saw that last week this is
certainly a side effect of this because
if the interest rate environment is so
low then the alternatives are rare and
stock markets are probably one of the
few alternatives we have probably apart
from real estate so how would you say
lenders can be encouraged to support
smaller businesses the ones that really
need the support at the moment the key
issue remains
the
restructuring of the banks many banks
are still in deep trouble and these
banks need to be resolved
restructured
some somehow there also might be a need
for additional equity injections so
banks just need to become solvent and
sustainable again what about the savers
at the same time as taking out loans you
know people will love this news what
about those who've just got their money
parked to banks and hope that they'll
get some sort of return on it because if
we take a look at the benchmark interest
rate for the eurozone it wasn't all that
bad back at the beginning of 2008
it's only gone down from there though
and with rates so low it's not the best
time to be a saver is it no for savers
it's really um a really bad time so
savers necessarily need to look for
alternatives and this may actually uh be
the reason for the stock market increase
okay mr rojo stay where you are we'll
get back to you in a minute